un chromosome supplémentaire la
naissance et voilà un mongolien lors
vous serez demain le père ou la mère
mongolien c'est ainsi que les
trisomiques 21 été nommé dans les médias
dans les années 60
en 50 ans l'image des trisomiques a
changé autrefois ils étaient perçus
comme un fardeau pour la société
exemple dans les années 70 une
journaliste va à la rencontre des
habitants d'un village qui accueille un
centre d'handicapés mentaux dont des
trisomiques et voilà la réaction du
maire il ya l'aspect physique et puis
l'aspect mental tout tout s'enchaîne
vous avez des jeunes enfants qui sont
traumatisés et de voir déambuler ces
malades
l'ofj pourtant c'est bien grâce à ces
établissements que le regard de la
société va évoluer pour la première fois
la journaliste tend le micro à ces
personnes resté longtemps sans voix est
ce que tu es heureux
oui pourquoi je regrette
fouillez picking accueille bien
accueillis dans les années 80 certains
enfants trisomiques intègre l'école
ordinaire
là encore c'est grâce à la détermination
individuelle de leurs parents et six
pour les petits camarades
il n'y a pas de différence pour les
autres parents et les journalistes
ça reste un événement unique à
l'ordinaire un matin comme tous les
matins et des enfants pas vraiment comme
les autres pas la même tête il parle pas
pareil
nous on dit mongolien leurs parents
district de mic en 1996 un film avait
marqué un tournant dans l'acceptation de
ce handicap le huitième jour réalisée
par jaco van dormael rencontrera un
immense succès et l'acteur pascal
duquenne atteint de trisomie recevra le
prix d'interprétation masculine à cannes
pour ses parents d'enfants trisomiques
c'était un grand pas contre les préjugés
ce jeu me dis oh ça va changer le regard
des gens sur la trisomie les initiatives
personnelles se multiplient pour un
accès à l'école aux sports à l'art et
les regards changent lentement comme par
exemple le regard de ce professeur de
danse en 2007
et ça ça circule ça respire ça bouge ça
voilà
non moi ça me ça m'apporte ça me donne
ça grandit avec en france
cinquante mille personnes seraient
porteuses de trisomie 21
les associations militent pour rendre
l'école et le monde du travail inclusifs
car si le regard de la société a évolué
dans les faits c'est toujours un
parcours du combattant pour les parents
d'inclure leurs enfants dans le milieu
ordinaire
[Musique]